hello hello good morning morning all
we'll be getting started in just a few
moments um but uh good morning for those
of you in US time zones good afternoon
for those of you possibly in European um
and good I don't know maybe we have some
good evenings I'm not entirely sure um
but it's good to see you all we're like
I said we're going to get started in
just a couple of moments but allowing a
few people to get in and uh get
connected
um David good to see you this time not
in a car but with an epic painting of a
bull behind you that is pretty Majestic
back there
thanks I like it do you do you is there
a story to that particular painting um
or you just liked it it came with a
house name of my uh coaching company is
helping Bulls thrive in China shops
so very very
my
bra I love it and so did you did you
find that were you in a like gallery and
you saw that and you're like that's
perfect did you have a commission did
you make it I wish I could take credit
it was my lovely wife saw it somewhere
and said I'm getting it for you
so oh that is uh amazing maybe I need a
painting of a big smiley face for a
while actually up against this wall over
here on this side of my wall is um some
abstract art from a very local artist um
local to the fact that she lives with me
and is a
three-year-old there you go we switched
things up so uh yeah like I said welcome
everyone we're gon to be getting started
in just a moment with our session today
to uh speak like a pro I'm checking some
settings on my side I think my zoom is
kind of acting weird uh Dave can you go
ahead and speak let's see if there's any
there's three Daves in here today Ah
that's true Dr Dave
um are you all able to hear him okay M
there's a little bit of static anyone
hearing any static or anything from me
or other
people not either no okay it's just my
headphones then um which is uh a better
scenario um very cool so it is five past
the hour I think we're gonna be having
people join us as we come through but uh
welcome to the May virtual happy hour
from humor that works uh if you have not
joined does previously before uh this is
an opportunity for us to get together we
talk about a subject that is on top of
our IM Minds that we want to share out
with other people that we think can
provide a little bit of impact and give
you a chance to step away from uh the
often negative news cycle and constant
kind of grind of everyday life and uh
take a little bit of time to focus a
little bit on yourself in some
particular topic usually related to the
broader context of humor in the
workplace to use humor as a skill to get
better results in work and in life uh so
that's who we are humor that works uh
this particular week we have a very
special guest we're going to be talking
about speaking like a pro uh so tips
that you can use to improve presentation
skills whether that is something that
you want to do because you give
presentations at work or because you're
interested in becoming a keynote speaker
or something anywhere in between all of
that joining me today is special guest
uh uh this person is a PhD in
Communications he teaches Coes such as
leadership and conflict resolution
public speaking skills and the rhetoric
of humor he uh happens to also be my
brother uh Dr Dave welcome to this
virtual happy
hour thank you um what's exciting is I
didn't know you were talking about me at
first and I was getting excited like oh
who's our special guest oh I have a PhD
in communication too we so much in
common
impressive yeah I love it I yeah so uh
if you can tell from uh like the last
name yes we are related and uh Dave and
I recently did a tedex talk uh together
we gave a joint talk on the subject of
uh what kind of funny are you which is
probably going to be coming out soon
what's interesting about tedex is you
don't know the exact release date and it
could be coming out as soon as probably
like next week or maybe within the next
month uh so we'll share more about that
we can share more about that at the end
because we have a special launch Team
that we're going to be putting together
for that particular talk and uh Dave and
I were going through a lot of prep for
that talk and there's a couple things
that we realize with that talk one I
realized that I apparently am looking
older these days because uh throughout
our prep people kept on asking which one
of us was older between Dave and I uh
which uh hopefully you all can tell
quick poll um if you want go ahead and
drop in our quick show of hands or drop
in the chat who do you think is older
Dave
or me anyone think uh quick show of hand
if you think it's Dave you can raise
your hand I can see those anyone think
it's me that's
older um it's it's sad that uh it's sad
that it's even a question anymore
because I am younger by two and a half
years and um uh it used to be growing up
no one ever asked that question of like
who's older they knew but apparently as
we've gotten a little bit older it's now
a question in people's minds uh I think
it's maybe because of just my sheer list
of accomplishments is that what it is
Dave I think is it your long hair I
don't know it's because I don't have a
receding hair
line um and maybe maybe you do you know
any other guest that I brought on that
said that would immediately Boot It Be
boot it from the zoom but I don't want
to get a call from Mom later uh about
that and also I don't know how you could
say something so hurtful and yet so
true you know I I I I take medicine so I
don't have a hair problem so but I keep
telling you to do the same and you won't
do it that's true that's true this is
your way of of publicly getting you to
do it yeah yeah uh well uh one of the
other things that we Rec yeah real quick
I just wanted to uh not share my screen
for a second to shout out to someone
since we like to shout out yeah but Kyle
I've been using your uh image of myself
for years as my um as my screen
background so I just wanted to show that
real quick
oh yes absolutely thank you Kyle it is
it's an incredible drawing of Dave uh
it's his uh when he's not showing his
video it is what he is is showing there
so K thank you for uh for the wonderful
art uh it's good to also to see you um
the uh so for the uh for the the the
tedex talk we realized that our
preparation techniques were very very
different because I am someone who is
pretty planned and meticulous when it
comes to any type of presentation that I
do particularly something like a tedex
talk my goal is to essentially almost
run it as many times as possible making
iterations across uh you know along the
way and uh Dr Dave's process is
decidedly uh not vet um uh he's very
much more uh what how would you classify
your your preparation Style just very
high level Dave procrastination until
the end and then a lot of panic tears um
and no I'm just kidding uh but not as
much uh preparation as you do I like to
um kind of come up with the ideas not
the exact words and and try and share
the ideas worth spreading not the the
words worth spreading yeah okay uh and
so uh quick uh we're going to dive
deeper into that today share a little
bit more background about our individual
processes and then we're also going to
leave time for Q&A kind of at the end um
to talk about some things but to get
things started out would be curious go
ahead and drop in the chat I'm curious
as a little poll what style of
preparation presentation prep do you
tend to do now are you more of the uh
meticulous kind of uh scripted more like
me or are you more of the extemporaneous
or kind of off-the-cuff life like Dave
or are you something else go ahead and
drop in the chat what your kind of
current presentation style is just so we
can get a sense of who we have in the
room today uh because I think there's
opportunity to learn from both both of
those so um uh yeah I think there's you
know and it also depends on the type of
presentation that you're going so I like
we have a mix so like write it down and
run through it a number of times uh not
quite scripted but certainly prepared um
and outline with extemporaneous
extemporaneous need to prep a lot fluid
over prepared to be ready to Pivot for
the audience right so there's a whole
mix of these things bullet point score
idas right so we've got a good mix and
so what we will do today is we're going
to share a little bit of background
about both of our processes
I'll give you my kind of process and
then Dave will give his uh and then like
I said we'll open up that to Q&A as we
go through um to share this as well um
let me move things around a little bit
here uh yeah so uh for my side because I
am planned uh I have like actual slides
and things that I want to share uh and
so that's what we have today like you
said we're talking about sleep uh speak
like a pro and uh this is now my process
this is what I do to kind of prep for
most of my uh keynote events so a little
bit of background if you're not fam what
kind of our work uh I uh run humor that
works and deliver keynote presentations
uh to large organizations as well as do
some trainings and offsites in addition
to these weekly or these monthly kind of
virtual happy hours and other fun stuff
that we get into but my process
particularly for Keynotes the type of
presentations that I do the most it
starts with a it's a 10-step process
because I'm an engineer of course it is
and it starts with the script and the
script starts for me usually as a very
messy outline it's kind of writing the
bullet points high level of like this is
the content or the types of things that
I know that I want to talk about and for
me it also includes a section of like
include somewhere at the bottom I
include my notes and it's like okay I
know somewhere I want to talk about
these things I don't know where it's
going to go but that's that first draft
of the outline because when it comes to
using humor which we can talk a about a
little bit about later when it comes to
adding humor to your presentation
there's a couple ways you can come up
with it one you can uh have something
that you need to tell people and say
okay how do I make this thing funny
right okay I've got to talk about uh in
this presentation I need to talk about
leadership and specifically I want to
talk about uh the gap between intention
and action and so okay hey how do I make
that content on what we call Un
leadership funny so that's one way to
add humor another way to add humor is to
take something that you already know is
funny either because it's a story that
you tell your friends and family and it
always gets them the laugh or it's a
meme that you saw somewhere that you're
like hey this is somewhat related to to
leadership or it's a video that you want
to share Etc but it's like hey I have
this thing that I I know is funny I want
to see if I can insert it some way I
will add that in my notes at the bottom
to say okay how do I get this in here so
one example of that is in my tedex talk
on the skill of humor which came out a
few years ago uh we I I was doing this
series of jokes in standup that I knew
worked it was math pickup lines right
because I'm a I'm a nerd I uh love math
and so I made this joke about like you
know math pickup lines the idea of say
you know they're terrible pickup lines
things saying things like you know hey
girl are you uh opposite over hypotenuse
because you're making me want to sin
right that's a terrible math pickup line
right but it was something that I did in
standup that I knew worked and got
laughs and so I was like okay how can I
insert that into the presentation
because I know it's somewhat related to
the skill of humor and so then it took
me a little bit of time to find that
like oh well using pickup lines is kind
of about confidence using humor is also
about confidence now I can connect these
dots so uh that is I think one uh one
thing that took me a while to learn is
like when you're outlining things you
can include the things like yes this is
kind of the overall flow that I need and
also here are things that ideally I
insert uh and they may not always go in
but they often can find a way you can
find a way to map that in there so
that's the scripting process it starts
with an outline then I do another
version of it that's Bare Bones also the
other thing I think about scripting for
people if this is something that you're
nervous about is recognizing that it is
perfectly acceptable to just say insert
funny thing here right Dave you probably
remember the first iterations of the
script that we went through the tedex
talk there's a lot of here are things to
say and then here are like insert comic
triple or insert funny punchline like
your first kind of iteration or attempt
at writing something doesn't have to be
the you know super funny version of that
thing but rather just here's the rough
thing that I want to talk about and then
in future iterations you're going to
improve it so that's kind of the third
version of my script is going through it
and kind of getting all the words down
and and working on the uh adding the
humor to it uh up next is the slides so
step two is in creating the slides or
any visuals that you're going to use uh
and for me the slides help me to also
think a lot of time I'm reorganizing the
script as I think about the slides of
how I'm going to walk through things
first version is rough slides again
notes to self of like insert picture of
blank or fine picture of blank because
uh if you're like me sometimes you're
like oh I want to I want to put it a
really interesting picture here but you
going to search for unsplash for that
picture somewhere else can lead you down
a rabbit hole that you're like 45
minutes you're later and you're still
looking at pictures of uh you know the
the perfect picture of a cat hanging on
a tree because that's what you want to
insert in there and you have been
actually working on the script and so
version one of the slides is okay what's
the rough version of the slide and then
you can iterate on those in the future
step three is a solo run through what um
there's a great book called The
referable Speaker uh which is by Michael
port and Andrew Davis it's about if
you're interested in the keynote side of
the world if you're interested in kind
of becoming a professional uh speaker uh
it's a great book on that in it it
references what they call their
seven-step rehearsal process uh what
Michael and Amy Port learned from their
years of being in um in the theater
world uh it's what this this step is
what they call a table read so it's the
idea of you saying these things out loud
that you want to say because sometimes
you write the perfectly craft sented to
say and then you realize it's super
awkward to say because it's suddenly
eight you know C sounds in a word in a
row and it's very hard for you to kind
of you stumble through it every single
time you say it so saying things out
loud helps give you an iteration step
number four is in what you'd call what I
call an alpha run through or what they
call an invited rehearsal so that's the
idea of like okay let me get one maybe
two other people that I want to hear
this talk because just by having to say
it in front of someone else it elevates
one your performance of it and two it
gives you really valuable feedback both
feedback in the sense of what the other
person says so you want this to be
someone who you trust their opinion and
also whose opinion of you isn't going to
change by seeing a very rough version of
this talk so it should probably be a
loved one or a close friend but what's
interesting about this Alpha run through
is I find the most value of it isn't
actually the feedback the other person
gives to me that can be valuable but
it's also what do I think to myself as
I'm saying it as I'm saying it or as I
notice like oh man I'm being really
boring right now or this is really uh
this part doesn't seem to be working or
other things right so you're getting
that feedback by actually saying it out
loud to other people after that you can
get into the memorization of uh the talk
and I put memorization quotes in here
because I will agree with what Dr Dave
is goingon to say in a little bit about
it's not necessarily about exact wrot
memorization it's not about how do I get
every single word exactly correct uh but
more about how do I get the overall
message down and this is like do I have
the overall flow of it one of the best
tips I learned about kind of this
process is uh initially sprang from
Jerry Seinfeld where he talked about his
material he wants to be so good he wants
to know his material so so well that
someone could be slapping him in the
face and he would still be able to tell
you what comes next and obviously I I
don't take that to extreme it's not like
I'm having Dave slap me in the face as
I'm going through the presentation uh
but instead I'm thinking about okay what
are other things that I can do that can
be slightly distracting that force me to
really make sure I know this material so
I A lot of times will go on a run or go
for a walk or if I'm doing the dishes or
if I'm doing a a a task that doesn't
take up uh my entire cognitive like load
then I will um uh I'll use that as the
opportunity to run through it doesn't
have to be perfect script but do I
remember what thing goes where and how
how this naturally flows through this
process I think is particularly helpful
because if there's a section that you
always forget then it may mean the
structure isn't kind of a natural flow
it may mean that you need to do some
reorganization and I think Dave that's
something that you and I experienced a
lot with the tedex talk as we realize
like what comes next from that it's like
oh that's because we don't have the
right through line to connect these dots
properly uh so that comes to the run
through uh step six then is the
performance how do you work on delivery
on blocking on where you're going to
stand when you say certain things what
visuals are going to be up when they
come up what timing do you want to kind
of keep in mind uh step seven is then
taking all of these things and doing
more of a beta run through so this would
be open rehearsal during repetition so
uh for those of you who have previously
joined joined our uh in the past when I
was doing my dry bar special recently we
went did this tedex talk uh when I was
working on a new keynote last year will
sometimes in the humor that works
Community take time to say hey okay
we're going to I'm goinging a rough
version of this talk where you come and
get feedback it's usually here at this
stage at step number uh seven okay uh
and then three more steps we've got the
dress rehearsal so this is doing the
presentation as close to the process as
uh possible um even kind of the on stage
day before or things like that in your
room like kind of trying to make a it
feel is very much like the presentation
I will say the dress rehearsal and even
the beta run through is delivering it as
if the audience was real so if you mess
up it's not about going back and being
like Oh what I meant to say was this
it's imagining as if it were an actual
live run through so if you do mess up
you've got to improvise your way around
that that mess up right so it's trying
to get a little bit more of that
practice in place uh then we get into
delivery and finally the debrief so the
debrief is a very underrated one uh
especially if you're going to be giving
a the same presentation multiple times
but even if you're not the debrief is
very valuable and the debrief I think
about you know how would you rate the
presentation how would you rate the
audience's response to it how would you
rate your own prep for it do you feel
like you actually prepped really well
for it or was it like I kind of waited
till last minute what would you keep for
the future what did you like that worked
really well what should you change uh
and then is there anything else you
should do differently for preparation at
all right so that is my very engineering
kind of 10-step process of prepping for
a
presentation and uh with that said um
I'll now turn it over to Dave to share
his uh his kind of overall process of
tips for things before we jump into Q&A
but hopefully that gives you a little
bit of a sense of the you know
engineering approach to a
presentation well thank you drew uh
as Drew said I am a public speaking
professor at Texas A&M University and so
this tedex talk was very difficult for
me because everything I teach in public
speaking we had to throw out the window
for a public uh for a tedex talk and so
the first uh process I guess that I
would help students with is knowing who
your your target audience is and who
your evoked audience is so who are you
pretending to be your audience and who
is going to be your audience for this
tedex talk we had a live studio audience
but that wasn't our Target art audience
it was you know the viewers at home and
so when you're viewing a speech the
rules are quite different than if you're
giving a speech in person um and so when
I do speeches it's usually in person I
have not had to do a tedex talk before
or a speech that is going to live in
Inon me and and time forever um so this
was was a very difficult process for me
with regards to Drew um doing a targeted
video audience as opposed to an
in-person live audience and what do you
just curious what do you think made it
harder was it the fact that it was a
tedex or was it the fact that you had to
do it with
me I I think both honestly because tedex
has some requirements like you have to
stand on the Red Dot I move quite a bit
during presentations uh and my movement
is part of the actual delivery of the
speech um and so not being able to move
without outside of that little red spot
but then having a partner where I
couldn't move at all so um in the video
I I don't know where to go I don't know
what to do with my hands because I'm
normally just more Naturally
Speaking um but I think what was harder
with the tedex talk was all of the
memorization which I'm opposed to so I
do uh prefer extemporaneous deliver and
I tell my students if they don't do
extemporaneous delivery if they do
memorization it's an automatic f um we
don't like memorization speeches because
they can't call on the moment they can't
live for the chyos they can't see if
something happens they can't rely on the
audience so an in-person audience for
instance Drew and I give speeches all
the time and his speech is probably the
same from location to location to
location where mine is completely
different based on who's in the audience
so if I have a very young audience I'm
going to be changing my examples live on
stage as I'm doing it versus if my
audience is um older or or more formal
then I'm going to maybe use some uh
lines or ideas from uh a presentation
that is more formal you know um for the
moment so Drew did a 10 process uh thing
that he had planned for you all and I
did not um but to do my process process
I did what Drew was doing during his
presentation was I was living in the
moment and trying to take notes of what
he was saying to see how it influenced
or just uh compare it and contrast it to
what I do so his first step is to write
a script my first step is to write an
outline vastly different um I don't
think you can write an introduction
until you've written the conclusion so I
don't even start with the introduction I
go for an outline for the main points I
practice each of those main points
separately um um and the way I do it is
I do it the number of times the speech
is going to be so like if I have a
10-minute speech I'm going to practice
each main point 10 times um just because
it's a 10-minute speech and these
practices are short and informal and
they're not like Drew where with Drew's
memorization if we messed up we needed
to go back and figure out what was the
line before whereas mine is like wait
that idea was kind of not how I wanted
to express it um if I have to give a
five minute speech I'll practice each
part five minutes now if I have to give
an hour speech I I'm not going to
practice it 60 times obviously but I I
do kind of stick with the shorter number
speeches that's the number of times I
practice it um his next step was the
slideshow I agree that I think using
PowerPoints is or any kind of
presentation is great but presentations
should enhance you not be the
presentation and so I tend to to skip
the slideshow until later um because I
don't want that to distract how I'm
going to deliver the message um so real
quick on on that right you I think you
often called them visual aids is that
right is is a slide technically a visual
aid are there other examples of visual
aids besid slid SL shows well yeah you
can use any kind of visual aid you could
use uh some students bring in actual
props uh Kyle could draw while she was
presenting perhaps right and that could
be part of her visual aid um there's
lots of you could use prey if you want
it to you could use video right um You
can use so yeah there's lots of
different visual aids but I tend to save
those for the End plus I think doing the
visual aid part is the fun part of the
speech so I want to save that to when I
have the least amount of energy um after
I practice each part separately I'm
going to practice the whole I'm going to
then write the introduction um and then
practice the whole speech one time uh as
together um and then after that I hope
for the best and I go into the situation
and I exude confidence Drew says as one
of the humor personas that I'm the
Entertainer which is somebody that's
just confident in their delivery and so
I think if you're confident in your
delivery you can mess up a couple of
times but still live in the moment and
not have a
rehearsal um there is one speech that I
do memorized on C on campus it's called
my yellow speech but it's a it's a very
serious topic and so
I do make that speech memorized because
the wording is very particular and I
live in a state where wording is really
important with regards to our funding so
that speech is memorized to the point
now that students who have seen it
several times can mouth along with it to
me and it gives me such cringe that
they're able to do that right I want
every experience to be new and unique um
so uh I don't start from scratch I
usually find an outline online um like
monrose motivated sequence if I'm trying
to sell something uh problem cause
solution if I'm trying to explain an
issue um cause and effect right I try
and find an easy outline online first
and then from that I can start inputting
Parts into the main points um again for
video audiences things can be different
so for in-person audiences I would never
go over three main points for a video
audience we have a little bit more
leeway so in our tedx talk we have seven
main points which um again was something
I wrestled with as a public speaking
teacher uh we usually have three or five
never more um so seven but I think what
we can argue is that because it's
virtual because it's online you can
pause the video to get all of those
points if you miss it um Drew did I
explain my process to your satisfaction
H yeah no I think I think that it uh
worked well and I know previously you
and I have talked and even related to
this you alluded to it is is you're less
about memorizing the word words and more
about really understanding the core
message or something along like the
lines like that right exactly yeah yeah
tedex is known for spreading ideas
wereth spreading which is great not
words worth spreading um specific words
and that's kind of my mentality too know
the material don't know the words don't
matter as much yeah that's specific yeah
and one of the things that you did
allude to and we're going to move to uh
a Q&A uh here shortly so if you have
certain questions and around the Q&A
we're very open to whatever it is that
you're really interested in learning so
you can either have specific questions
for uh Dr Dave or for me you can ask
more about the specific tedex process or
keynoting or speaking in general or
whatever it is whatever questions you
have in terms of uh that will can help
you in whatever kind of phase you are
within presenting we're happy to to
answer those questions um but one of the
things that uh Dave kind of mentioned or
alluded to is that there are different
types of speeches and I think there's
different ways to kind of C categorize
those I was thinking about this even for
um you know the the 10-step process that
I follow is like I don't do that for
every single presentation that I do uh
right so this uh this presentation here
speak like a pro or virtual happy hours
they tend to be much more of a fluid
state where it's based on kind of the
reactions and what's going on with the
room as opposed to hey I've memorized
this and written everything out multiple
times and so the way that I've thought
about um the presentations is maybe
impact of thinking about is it a low
stakes presentation or a high stakes
presentation right what are the like why
what are the stakes of that particular
presentation for whatever reason either
because of how it feels or because of
the potential impact or the results and
then also is it a one-off presentation
is it something that you are only ever
giving once or is it something you're
going to deliver multiple times right so
again me doing the humor that works
keynote that is iterative and to Dave's
point it uh is roughly the same for
audiences I would say it's probably 80
to 90% the same for audiences but then
there is customization for each group
and when you get better at memorization
like when you when you are really in
control of material that's when you can
at least for me that's when I can be
more present in the moment right it's
like stand I a lot of my process comes
from Dave's comes from being an actual
like getting his PhD in Communications
and being a public speaking Professor
Etc mine comes from the world of stand
up an improv and so standup is to the
point that you know once you get really
comfortable with your material you can
start to be more extemporaneous in the
sense of if something happens in the
room if there's crowd work or Heckler
Etc or whatever you're able to react and
then come back to what you want it to
say so it is it's not about pretending
like oh no matter what happens I'm going
to say these exact words and this exact
sequence for 60 minutes straight there
is still adjustment and customization
but that becomes a little bit easier
when it's something that happens
multiple times so and
to that point um I think it's funny to
mention that because we were trying to
do memorization speaking which I again I
don't usually do we finally get the
speech memorized but then a distraction
happens like our mom starts
laughing and I I could not I was I was
like well the speech is over because I
don't know what the next thing is
because she's laughing at one of our
jokes and so that's one of the issues I
have with memorization is if something
happens in the room it can really
distract from the message um but to your
point I think that that that is a great
idea that standup comedians really know
their their material so that they can
still be present so sorry to but I just
thought that was an interesting point
that like as soon as Mom laughed I
looked at you like well I have
nothing that was like hi I'm Dave you
know yep exactly yeah we had gone
through we had done the repetition so
many times of just us back and forth
that introducing laughter which is what
we were hoping for uh it shut down to
Dave's Dave
solution and this and this is how we are
different Dave's solution was to say
well maybe we just ask the audience not
to
laugh uh my solution was okay how do we
recreate the environment so we can
practice it and so we horrible it was a
horrible decision I wish we had recorded
that run through because my solution was
we gave my I I Googled laughter
soundboard
and we gave it to my mom so she listened
to it again and basically it was an
internet website that had random like
people's laughter like saved that she
could press a button and it would pick
that the problem is that what was
selected was a whole range of like some
of them were like haaha some of them
were like someone saying something and
then laughing like an evil scientist for
like 20 seconds and so then we had to do
this run through of trying to know what
we were supposed to say next with these
random laughter sounds kind of coming up
but to me that was the weight room of
kind of working out of like this is way
more distracting than it will actually
be in the the moment and so that should
help us and so for the most part it kind
of worked we did get through my solution
was just we just need more repetition
but you're exactly right like if you if
you do memorize and you memorize only in
a kind of very you know contained or
sanitary environment that may not be the
case when you get get up there and it
can throw you off so you do want to get
to the point that you also practice that
there might might be distractions now
all of that is for higher Stakes
presentations I think right so if I
think of like a oneoff low stakes
presentation that's maybe you know if
you have a weekly update that you're
giving your team and I can also um
Spotlight my camera just because I'm
realizing uh we're taking a look at some
of this stuff um is uh Team presentation
something like maybe on a weekly basis
you have to give a f minute update of
what you worked on uh right it's a
one-off presentation you're not going to
do it multiple times and relatively low
sticks uh right so that you don't have
to like prep quite as much uh right it's
not something where it's like okay I got
it through every through everything and
I got to go through it you know
thousands upon thousands of times it's
like nope I'm going to put together I
still want to get I still want to
deliver well but um it doesn't have to
be that heightened thing uh there's also
low stakes environments where you might
be giving yourself where you might be
doing it multiple times like say you're
at a networking event you're going to be
introducing yourself multiple times some
people an introvert like me if it's in
front of someone else I already think of
it in some ways as a presentation and uh
this in some ways is actually really
nice because anytime you're going to do
something multiple times the standup
comedian in me is like iterate on it
each time right even something of like
if you go to a networking event and
you're trying to think about how do I
answer that question of when people ask
so what do you do right each time you
say that try it a little bit different
say you're like okay I'm going to go and
I'm going to give a comic triple each
time I answer this question of like
someone says what do you do I'm going to
say uh you know I'm a keynote speaker a
coach and um Avid milkshake lover and
see if people laugh from that and if
they don't maybe the next person I meet
I'm GNA say hey I'm a a a keynote
speaker a uh coach and a father of a
three-year-old right like each time I'm
going to iterate a little bit and see
does that change the conversation which
of these things do I like how do I go
right anytime you do that multiple times
an easy spot to then iterate and learn
each time so it's getting better
as you deliver it multiple times then
you have the uh one-off presentations
that are still very high stakes for
whatever reason it's an update to a CEO
it's part of an interview process it is
a tedex talk this is where I would still
incorporate kind of from me that 10-step
process maybe not to quite the actually
probably to a higher degree than if I'm
doing multiple presentations of high
stakes which would be Keynotes because
this is what you know I'm paid to do or
sales pit is because it's a big part of
how you earn revenue is you need to get
the the sale Etc that's a similar thing
where it's like not only are you doing
am I doing the 10 step process then in
this case scenario but I am also
iterating on it each time that I go
through it so uh like I said there are
different times you're going to be doing
I do all steps all 10 steps in the high
stake scenarios and then in the low
stake scenarios typically it is steps
One two5 n and 10 so one being that uh I
am doing kind of some type of script for
it then I have to create slides or
visual aids if I need it I'm doing some
type of run through oftentimes just a
table read to myself I'm doing the
delivery and I am doing a debrief after
each thing because the other thing that
I'll say is that with these
presentations you each presentation is
not only a repetition for uh that
particular presentation it is also a
repetition of doing a presentation does
that make sense like as you have to do
more and more presentations you get
better at the process of prepping for a
presentation like Dave Dr Dave is
delivered lecture after lecture after
lecture for I get basically 10 years now
and so his process he know if he even
have even if he has to do a brand new
lecture he has a process that he can
follow because he's done hundreds before
and Dave that's probably where some of
your confidence comes from like you said
you step on St even if you're like a
little bit like hey I'm not perfectly
planned you step off on stage and sued
confidence well that's also because
you've successfully delivered lectures
and presentations hundreds of time
before right yeah you know I have
classes the size of 500 and I have
classes the size of like 20 and so I'm
uh constantly going between different
audiences and every day so that does
make it easier for
me um I do I don't have the butterflies
in my stomach when I present which is
good and so maybe I'm a little bit more
I lied um this is what I tell my
students All of You Are about to cringe
so be prepared to cringe um it's not
about killing the butterflies in your
stomach it's about getting them to fly
in formation for you um so again I know
that's a cringey thing to say but it is
something like I think it's kind of
poetic uh you know you want those
butterflies a little bit and I do get
them still even in when I go to give a
lecture for the you know uh my classes
um but it's not the butterflies that are
so overwhelming that I can't do anything
it's the okay let's let's get them to
fly information let's go let's get
energized welcome to a riveting class
guys um and and then I'm on um so I
forget what your point was but you're
you're exactly right I do do a lot of
repetitions of public speaking just
because of my profession I have to yeah
and that that makes it more comfortable
and that's where you kind of get some
changes so uh what I'd love to do is we
got a couple things that we want to to
wrap up with the m but I want to make
sure that we have time for Q&A or topics
things that you want to talk about so if
you have a specific question or a thing
that you're thinking about okay like
okay this is great this is all very high
level or um you know I have a specific
question or a thing that I really want
to know or that would help me in terms
of my presentation drop that in the chat
because we're happy to answer that or if
you want to raise your hand if you have
more of a verbal question that you would
like to ask or um share you you can also
raise your hand so I want to make sure
we're delivering against things that
would be really helpful for you again
you can direct it either to Dave myself
or ask it in general and allow people to
uh and allow us to kind of pick but
anyone have something you know kind of
top of Mind something they're wondering
about or you know they would like
Insight or suggestions
on give people a moment to think about
it um I would say you know as people are
thinking about their questions go ahead
and drop those in the uh the chat um how
do you um Dave how do you get prep what
are your steps of prepping like right
before a presentation right how do you
Wrangle those those uh butterflies to
get into shape or formation do you have
any like rituals techniques things that
you think about yeah I require all of my
students when uh we're doing public
speaking like all of them to stand up at
the same time right before every single
speech um and we all have to stand uh
Amy cuy Superwoman pose um uh we do that
constantly um and and that builds a lot
of confidence before speak speak I do
the same thing before a presentation I'm
making sure that my feet are shoulder
length apart that I'm standing proud and
not you know getting
nervous um that is that the kind of
thing you're talking about Drew yeah I
think it's help one of the things that I
do is um it's a um exercise we can do it
just for fun you've maybe done this
exercise uh before if you've joined some
of our previous programs but uh let's
see on your uh we'll say your right hand
uh give a thumbs up and Lan uh just your
finger point your finger out like that
right and now uh switch the
two right and switch back and forth
Kyle's got it down great Kyle's really
good at that uh some of you have finger
guns a little bit with the practice of
it um right but this is I like this is a
simple warmup warming up the left right
side of the body so warming up the left
and right side of the brain but this is
something that I started doing an improv
years ago anytime I was having a show we
would do it as a kind of a quick warm-up
and so it almost becomes like a
pavlovian thing so now when I do this I
know I'm getting ready to kind of quote
unquote Go on stage in some capacity and
so if you see me at a keynote or if you
were there at the tedex talk behind my
back I was doing this right before he
kind of went up just because it's like
my thing and so I think there is
tremendous value in rituals to say okay
this is my process of what I do it's the
same thing that batters do in baseball
before they get into the Batters box the
same thing that basketball players
before they take a three free throw Etc
just a physical thing to get yourself
into the mindset to say I'm about to do
this thing it may not feel like it does
a whole lot when you're first starting
out but if you do that before every
presentation your body does start to
connect when I do this I'm about to give
a presentation so um I think that can be
a great technique as well like whatever
those rituals are power poses Etc can be
a good one so uh Kyle has a dropped a a
great question in the chat and uh part
of it is kind of around how do we how
can we be consistent with our
personality and are are and be authentic
for it so she's saying you know she
often times organizes her structure like
me but then tries to deliver as Dave
abandoning kind of the plan and um I
think first of all I would say I think
that is a completely okay thing to do uh
Kyle if it does seem to be working for
you because the thing about
improvisation and this is what we talk
about in our leadership programs using
improv is that improvisation doesn't
necessarily have to mean like completely
winging it right A lot of times it's
about bringing your entire experience
and expertise into the moment and so
sometimes the work that you're doing
that it feels more meticulous like the
prep work the way that I prep is
actually what your brain needs to then
be able to deliver like a Dave in the
moment where you're like I wrote all
this script and this is one of the
things that a lot of times we we'll talk
about like and I didn't mention in the
delivery component is that once you get
to the delivery stage once you get to
the point that you're going to be in
front of other
people there's no like throw out the
script completely it's all about how do
I deliver a a a positive experience in
the moment right now not how do I make
sure that I say what's correct based on
what I planned before it's just all of
that work before it's kind of like you
know the the experience of like in
school where um they they there's like
various TV episodes and stuff about it
where it's like oh someone goes through
this like very meticulous way to cheat
they like okay so the first time I tried
writing down all the notes of what might
be on the test on a sheet of paper but
that was too big so then I rewrote it
this time and I put it here and then I
rewrote it on my hand and then end up
it's like that process that you doing to
try to cheat is actually what you needed
to be able to take the test any that you
were just studying in a way that you
thought was your planning to cheat the
same way of like this type of
preparation that is just a way to prep
so I think if it is working for you
right if you're getting positive
feedback and stuff like that it's
completely okay to um to accept that I
do think authenticity on stage is the
goal I mean Jerry Seinfeld said the more
the closer you can be your to your
authentic self on stage the funnier
you're going to be I also think it's
just something it's like you you want to
like if if if you could you know future
pace and say uh in five years I was
rocking it on the stage and either I
could be my authentic self or I could be
a
character like I would want to learn the
process of how do I rock it on stage as
my authentic self and the reality is a
lot of time those two things are a
little bit connect like when you can get
closer and closer to yourself you'll
find your audience and that doesn't mean
you're going to connect in front of
every audience that's what we discover
that part of what we talk about in the
tedex talk is that some people talk you
know connect with my style of humor some
people connect with Dave's style of
humor um but you then when you do find
your audience you really do find your
audience so hopefully that helps in
terms of the questions uh so Dr Cheryl
asked Dr Dave maybe you can answer this
one is research for structures of
speeches uh as as a function of the
situation or goal so you mentioned a few
of them in terms of the outlines or the
structures that you look at um
well uh my honest answer which I would
not tell my students but my honest
answer for you all is we live in the age
of um virtual assistance uh in the age
of AI and so one of the things you could
do is just type into AI like Google's um
AI right um I'm giving a speech I want
to persuade this
what is a good outline I can use um the
wording would be important so if your
speech is to persuade them to buy
something you would want to make sure
that I'm trying to sell them something
that's going to do a different outline
if you have a call to action include
that in your prompt because you're G
want to make sure that you ask your
audience to do something at the end um
so you can just I mean you don't even
need AI basically you could just do
Google and type in I need an outline for
X Y or Z when I get those mentioned you
mentioned you mentioned a few specific
ones though right so the so I know I can
name all of them if you want um but
there there's lots of them um so like uh
so for persuasion for instance if you've
ever watched Shark Tank they have to
follow Monroe motivated sequence for
persuasion um it is a cookie cutter way
to persuade um it is very
very cliche um and so if you watch Shark
Tank you'll see it's always the same
steps that they're doing to sell a
product but we also know it's very
persuasive um and it does get people to
buy I think that Monro motivated
sequence is wonderful as a first draft
but I never use it for my actual speech
I want to adapt it and change it a
little bit um problem cause solution is
an easy one if you have an issue that
you're trying to address um cause and
effect if you're trying to look at
what's making things happen
[Music]
um uh there's uh I mean I could get you
a whole list if you want Drew but again
I think the EAS would that be I mean I'm
interested in that would that be helpful
as like some type of like handout or
takeaway or something like that if we
had like a table of like this type of
talk this type of structure I mean it'
be helpful for me I don't know I'm I'm
adding work for Dave but no it's not
that much work my fear is that people
would use it as the word of God and
again these outline are for drafts not
for the actual presentation and so it's
one of those things like I want to show
my students but at the same time it's
like look this is what you can do okay
now do your thing based on these ideas
but don't make it so cookie cutter that
it's it it's not
authentic but yeah and so you were gonna
say okay what you do with those outlines
because I have a I have a similar kind
of idea and I think people kind of
recognize that they're like okay yeah
this is just it's it's kind of the idea
of like okay so rather than starting
with a completely blank page let me
start with this structure and then yeah
you can all it's it's like the it's like
following Joseph Campbell's you know
Heroes Journey or uh Dan Haron Story
Circle if you're going to write a story
Etc it's like you could kind of like
once upon a time there was blank and
every single day blank happened and
because of that blank and because of
that because of that until one day and
then finally right that's the story
spine so you can do that to write a
story but that might be your first draft
and then you can recognize like oh maybe
I want to put the end at the beginning
to create a little bit of tension or
maybe I want to add here so the
execution of it so I would say like yeah
these these structures can be that yeah
like you said they're the very they're
the the starting blank page of something
but not the end all be all I would say
one that I follow from a keynote
perspective uh comes from tamson Webster
it's called the Red Thread and it
structure is basically like most like
she's helped a lot of people at tedex
talks and things like that it is um goal
the audience has uh problem that uh
prevents them from achieving that goal
that they don't they probably don't
recognize the uh idea or truth about
that particular problem the change
that's needed to implement that idea or
Implement that truth and then the
actions you need to take to um put those
into to to make that change reality
right and so a lot of times I'll use
that as a rough framework because her
book has that very structured and for me
as an engineer it is very much that like
okay she even has like an outline rubric
where you're like answer this question
so I would do that and then it's like
that would make for a terrible speech it
it has the high Lev points but it would
not be an interesting speech but from
there if you iterate on it um can be
really valuable so I think that is
something interesting that we'll try to
put together because I think could be
something to to share and would be
helpful for me of like oh I want to you
know I want or if I just want to switch
things up if I want to try things a
little bit differently I don't know if
this would be cringe but I could put my
lecture in the chat that talks about
this stuffff yeah is that is that
publicly available yeah it's on YouTube
um okay so you'll see how my teaching
style is and maybe you'll like it or not
like it I don't know but that's uh that
is an organization that uh lecture that
kind of goes through it and halfway
through it talks about a variety of
different approaches but I could also
then Drew um I'm getting ready to get on
a plane but if you remind me later this
afternoon when I get um to my
destination I could create a list and
when you would use yeah I think it' be
interesting for sure um let's see for
tanging a couple of other quick
questions yeah as as someone else shared
in the chat um uh as Dave shared in the
chat used a tool called prey video um so
prey itself is the presentation software
a lot of people are aware of they have a
standalone application uh called prey
video which just allows you to do
picture and picture slides allows you to
zoom in ETC I like it because you can't
if you're good at prey then you can
create in prey and then do all this kind
of wonderful stuff I'm not good at prey
but what I like about prey video is you
just download the application and then
you can import your PowerPoint
presentation and it creates it as slides
on the kind of picture and picture side
so that's what I do is just a quick
thing on the slides um I have H three
pair Kathy's questions do I have lucky
socks I have three pairs of socks that I
tend to present in just because I like
them so one is a a a set that has ducks
on them uh cuz when my daughter was
really young she loved ducks and she
help pick them out at the store she saw
like ducks or whatever so I was like oh
I put them on because it makes me think
of her um I have a pair that is um just
like colorful and playful that I like
and then I have a pair of Bob Ross socks
so I think that they're like fun and and
playful as well um Dave has hundreds of
socks I don't know if you still do
themes with your socks or not yeah I
have a different pair for every day of
the year multip pairs for different days
of the year
um um yeah so Angel has the question of
like you know used to be great in
speaker mode then you built up skills
and facilitation and now you're like me
doing all the Talking versus not speaker
mode versus facilitation mode any
suggestions on working through um that I
think part of it is for me uh Angel it's
it's having knowing what's
best for that particular speech because
uh a lot of
times by default we we might think like
oh but I know from learning Etc that
it's always better to have other people
do the thing it's always better to have
them engaged and involved and we might
feel like and and theoretically maybe in
terms of an actual like being able to
take home a specific skill that may be
true but there still are certain
scenarios where I think it's better
Andor faster just to be in presenter
mode and recognizing those cases so
Keynotes and this is something that at
least for me I ask my clients on a scale
of 0o to 100 in terms of amount of
Engagement how much do you want and some
of them are like as much as you can in
which case we might throw out the slides
and only do applied improv exercises I
also speak to a lot of uh engineering
groups and you know mathematicians and
scientists Etc and they're like we at
all we don't want to do any interaction
and I'll still do a little bit of
interaction but it's like they know like
we want this to feel like a show we want
this to be more of a presentation and so
I think thinking about that and
recognizing those cases if you're giving
like if you have five minutes and you've
got to get through a decent amount of
data it's like okay that's going to be a
presentation if you have 90 minutes and
it's like okay I can bring in a little
bit of both and so I think it's it's
mentally recognizing what's Best in
service of this particular message to
this particular audience decide on one
and then after that hopefully that can
get you into like okay I've decided this
is best to be speaker mode let me go
back to that skill set that I know that
exists of me being a good speaker um
right but it's once you kind of confirm
in your head that this is the best style
for that particular message I think a
lot of the other stuff will probably go
away I one of the things that I put in
the comments is that improv is one of
the best activities for public speaking
and I I don't know Angel if you're
familiar with improvisation but um that
really really helps with that balance I
know exactly what you're talking about I
gave a presentation to the un uh fpf the
United Nations population fund um last
year in November I think think and it
was a 4-Hour presentation so it was a
little bit of like me presenting and
then going into facilitation and then
back presenting and then back to
facilitation um and you do like you're
on when you're presenting and then you
go into facilitation mode and it's kind
of like well this is a different
authentic me I guess if you would say um
but what I did was I tried to I I'm
reminded of my improvisation training
with regards to like the hype man and I
just go around um to each group that I'm
facilitating kind of walk around the
room and just pretend to be the hype
person and just hype of everybody's idea
that hype keeps me hyped for then when I
get back on stage to go into
presentation mode um but it is I and I
know I kind of understand what you're
talking about with that transition and
how you can
um get that balance between there um
Drew came to my I taught public speaking
you know 15 years ago and Drew came down
when he was a stand-up comedian and he
taught my class improvisation for one
day and after a 15we semester right so
they had me for 45 days they had Drew
for one day all of my student evaluation
said Drew's life or Drew's class changed
my life I really love Drew's class Drew
this drew that and I'm like dang you had
me for 15 weeks and and my name's not
even mentioned in my
evaluations that's when I realized how
important improvisation was to the art
of public speaking and since then it it
really does I think is um I I mean you I
might be speaking to the choir but I
really think that's one of the best
things you can
do yep I I agree because like I said
improvisation is not about uh winging it
it's about bringing you know the the
bulk of your some of your experience
expertise and insight into the present
moment and adapting and so uh can be a
great skill and and plus it's a whole
lot it's a it's a way more fun way to
practice than some of the other ways
right and so you can get great value of
that so that can be as simple as
Googling improv classes in my area there
are online classes as well we
periodically do things in the humor
networks community of very impr we
haven't done anything in a long time so
maybe we should do something virtual
again um or there's also groups that you
can bring into your organization right
so if you're part of a company you could
say like hey can we do a improv team
building thing it's something that we at
humor that works do and other groups do
very quickly as people I know we're uh
towards the end of the hour I do want to
mention uh so our tedex talk is going to
be coming out um very very soon uh we
are putting together what we are calling
a launch Team for that particular talk
so I just dropped the link into the chat
um if you go to humor. me/ um launch or
scan the QR code on our screen you can
uh uh sign up for the launch Team if
you're interested what we're doing with
the launch team is one you'll see the
Talk Sooner because we're going to send
you out a um uh the the video as soon as
it comes out two you'll get free access
to our book called the skill of humor
Playbook uh and then also we're going to
have some exclusive behind the scenes
content that we're going to share also
one winner from the launch team is going
to get a free coaching session from
either Dave or I and one winner is going
to receive the whole humorous course uh
and it's also just a huge way to help us
out essentially joining the launch Team
just means that yeah you'll see the the
talk as soon as it comes out we're going
to ask you to do things like you know
watch The Talk comment on it maybe share
it with other people if you know other
groups other newsletters that might
enjoy this stuff or Facebook communities
or other places that uh would enjoy the
talk the whole goal is just to you know
to we're really proud of and we think
can um have a positive impact on
people's lives so we just want to get in
in front of a lot of different people so
again you can join the launch Team there
uh for some of those goodies Etc um also
we do this every single month with
different topics so if you have topics
or ideas that you would like for us to
cover uh certainly let us know but we'll
also create some more uh content maybe
around some of the uh presentation
skills because it seems like something
that people like and uh need as a fit uh
but thank you all so much for uh joining
and uh I've got a little bit of time as
well so I'm going to stick around so if
you have you know kind of more casual
questions or conversation uh happy to be
here Dave I think you've got to run to
an airport um for a flight um so Dave Dr
Dave is gonna say bye as he heads out up
headed to Ohio for an event um but like
I said I'm happy to stick around if you
have any specific questions but thank
you so much for joining us today for
this virtual happy hour and we'll
hopefully see you again sometime soon
thanks Drew I am gonna jump off bye
everyone all right
bye I leave that there I guess hello
hello how are you Kyle it's been a
little while I think since I've seen
you uh you're on mute
s it has been a while yeah I've just
been uh trying to Define what it is I do
because it's such now a mix of improv
and you know I never did tell you this
uh
thing after I listened to your talk at
one of the
conferences uh I was on uh the
interstate in Pennsylvania Turnpike and
I determined I was going to be able to
do do it and I missed my exit ended up
having to go 30 miles out of my way
because I was on the steering wheel just
going like that doing like this well I
will say the practice paid off I mean
ITA didn't help in that moment but
you're very good at it now and it's like
riding a bike I find that practice is is
so important and uh I can't seem to help
myself I still end up
drawing when I am uh that is amazing I
think it's a great way to stay engaged
in someone presenting can you take a
picture of that and send that to me I
will scan it and and send it to you it's
got my notes on it because and socks of
course the lucky socks we talked about
them absolutely right right but uh and
speaking about improv you said this was
casual uh I was hired to do uh come to a
memory memory care
facility and typically when I go to
someplace I I stand up I I draw my
caricatures but I make my subjects now
play an improv game it will a
modification of an improv game where I
give the next person in line a script
and I make the person I'm drawing has to
perform what the script says and it's
basic social skills so the first thing
on the script is say hello introduce
yourself wave to the audience then it
gets a little wiggle J jigle with an
attitude jiggle do a thumbs up and wink
and bark you know then it it gradually
moves into bark like a dog bark like a
little dog and it's interesting to see
the dynamic of power so as uh of course
with memory care most of these people
didn't have the cognitive ability to
respond to
questions so I ended up having to flip
into telling
stories and essentially doing what I
always wanted to do which was practice
speaking you know standup comedy almost
on the spot but because of I'm a
caricature artist you know I have three
minute stories three minute four minute
five minute depending on how long the
drawing takes where I do present so um I
I just think that doing that for memory
care or going into an elder care to
practice your your speech would be a
gift back to the audience and many of
them are are still all cognitively there
for the most part and they're very
intelligent people and you can get
feedback so afterwards I was able to say
well how did that go for you guys and
was this worth presenting because I had
to abandon my easel which is my uh lus
blanket Y and it was just me exposed
speaking so I just thought I'd throw
that out there for anybody that might be
interested in an alpha run through that
yeah no I love that as a great way to
get a run like right and I think whether
it's yeah it can be I think volunteering
speeches in general can be a great thing
whether it's specifically meem memory
care or nonprofit organizations or other
things like it's a great way to get
repetitions of the the speech and to
give back at the same time and I think
what a really interesting way I mean you
could probably do that on on stages if
you're speaking in front of even a
little bit of a larger audience you
could do that thing of like rather than
just giving the speech you could like
have you ever done that of like give
like draw someone while also giving
people content or a story or something
like that could be it' probably be a
thing that people would be like really
impress impressed with of like wait you
can talk and draw this caricature at the
same time I have I have done that a lot
oh that's amazing as many as a group uh
my biggest issue is finding a way to to
record it and document it right so that
it's online that says this is what I do
and this is how I do it and uh I've
hired a couple different people at times
to try to capture those those moments
and it it hasn't been done well enough
so if you know any good social media
managers I think that's what I need
somebody I I can draw I can talk and I
can speak at the same time but I I
cannot also record myself doing right
exact you need someone someone there
yeah but that's evolving I do it for the
Virginia Association of Commonwealth
attorneys and that's a tough crowd right
there yeah but I didn't do it on stage
but that's my goal is yeah doing it on
stage I think would be really
interesting like you said if you can get
video or something of it of like any
like if it's staged or potentially a
breakout for aat or something like that
in the future a thing like where it is
like uh like hey you do this or even
even applied improv Network or whatever
but if there's a place that you can do
it then like have yeah maybe even
multiple people like it's in a friendly
environment like that you could try to
get hey can I get a couple people to try
to record this a couple different angles
because it is a it's not something that
I've heard of before and is a really
like would be a thing that like oh once
you see it you can kind of like
experience it you for joining um so um
yeah I don't want to hog your stage here
yeah well thank you for for joining uh
to to Sue I'm not sure if you're there
but thank you it's always lovely to see
your your smiling um um picture face as
well and and Katie as well Kyle thank
you so much for uh for joining and uh
yeah it was great to catch up as well